globalement quand on critique Aya
Nakamura elle aime pas ça elle a dit
fermez vos gueules quoi c'était pas du
tout dessiné à Nicoletta voilà merci
merci
scandaleux
écoutez vous avez vu la violence elle
remue ses fesses c'est un produit
maladie pareil de Daniel Moreau je suis
désolé
pour ça extrêmement violent pour aller à
Nakamura qui mérite pas ça qui est une
femme formidable une artiste
extraordinaire tu la connais on est fier
de l'avoir mais non je l'admire est-ce
qu'a dit
ça serait trop beau je n'y crois pas
mais merci quand même mais franchement
ce caddy Nicoletta ça dépasse
l'entendement
elle a un talon énorme
fait on peut comprendre qu'il y avait
certains qui aiment pas sa musique mais
c'est une des plus grandes artistes
françaises aujourd'hui c'est la plus
écoutée dans le monde l'artiste
française la plus équilibrée dans le
monde ça se respecte elle est elle est
pas vulgaire elle est sexy c'est c'est
une Queen c'est comme Beyoncé c'est
notre Beyoncé à nous alors regardez Anne
Roumanoff parce que ah non manov c'était
sur RFM elle était invité de l'excellent
Bernard Montiel et elle a pas hésité à
prendre la défense de la chanteuse selon
elle Aya sur les victimes de racisme
elle en a même profité pour ajouter
qu'elle trouvait la chanteuse
extraordinaire elle était au micro d'un
certain Bernard Montiel un animateur en
vogue regarde
je trouve en France il y a un mépris
pour elle parce que parce que c'est une
femme parce qu'elle est noire parce que
elle a pas les codes de certains trucs
elle est très originale elle est
féministe elle est libre elle est sexy
elle envoie chez tout le monde elle a de
l'humour moi j'ai vraiment je la trouve
elle est elle est très intelligente en
plus
à Nicoletta qu'est-ce que tu veux non je
dis j'adore ah non maintenant mais ça
j'en peux plus donc on ne peut plus
critiquer que les hommes blancs quoi
parce que si on critique une femme
d'accord mais excuse-moi on peut ne pas
aimer à kamura
est-ce qu'on fait du Sandrine Rousseau
maintenant si on critique une femme
c'est parce que c'est une femme si on
critique une femme
on aurait dû pouvoir que critiquer les
hommes blanches je suis désolé et il y
en a partout ça me gonfle elle en a
rajouté
quand les gens
tu aimes ça mais pourquoi
mais ferme ta gueule beaucoup plus
intéressante que plein de chanteuses
vendent auxquelles tout le monde se
prosterne alors oui mamie oui Non Non
mais j'ai donné mon avis
généralement elle a parce qu'elle n'aime
pas dans les codes et parce qu'elle est
noire elle a subi
regardez Gilles tout à l'heure qui nous
a quand même dit qu'il fallait pas
critiquer
aujourd'hui bravo critique que les
hommes blancs mais c'est complètement
réac c'est n'importe quoi
elle est parée c'est une vieille
personne laisse-la
les femmes politiques maintenant nous
avons vu ce qu'on peut pas les critiquer
parce qu'elles sont des femmes et si on
est misogyne il y en a marre jusqu'au
bout si vous voulez être légal des
hommes acceptez qu'on vous critique
comme n'importe qui on critique
réellement comme n'importe quoi
laissez-la parler elle kiffe à pas
parler de l'émission elle
va se coucher dans une heure de merde
Aya Nakamura je suis pas chaude
c'est un argument bizarrement qui est
hyper basique et que personne n'a encore
sorti pour ça je pensais pas parti pour
débat mais en fait il y a simplement un
choc des générations
il y a rien de dramatique après Nicolas
dit que Aya est un produit Nicolas est
un produit aussi Aya est un produit elle
se vendent leur travail je vois pas où
est le problème mais il y a juste un
choc des générations Nicoletta elle
pouvait paraître vulgaire à son époque
peut-être
il y a rien de grave